let me uh actually pull this tweet up
from dave rubin because there's a lot
more context in this we have the tweet
from dave rubin himself he says hey elon
musk as long as you're digging check
into how new york times forbes etc
bought their twitter followers to fake
influence
new york times has 53 million followers
and rarely gets 50 retweets i could post
a banana emoji and a pic of an 80 sitcom
star and get more see next tweet okay
here is dave's next tweet it is an 80s
sitcom star with a banana and has 7 718
retweets god bless her now
elon musk responded i noticed that
i noticed that too pretty weird
everyday astronaut says conversely for
some reason the last two days my account
suddenly got 30 000 followers a day and
we've done nothing different it's far
beyond our average one to two k per day
you're not going to convince me that
that is all organic i responded to elon
musk so elon said almost every media
outlet on earth wrote about me acquiring
twitter causing a massive influx of new
users i just want to point out there was
no influx on the monday this is
announced take a look at this
so social blade is gmt by the way so
that's london time
sure sure so just to take that in
consideration absolutely and it's
possible i was saying that they don't
they calculate everything by like 5 p.m
that still doesn't explain how on 2 on
the 20 so whoever's account that says
every day astronauts right so 3 p.m
look at the averages would be what 8 p.m
on 4 24 3 000 on 420 come on 3 000 on
four twenty five three thousand three
thousand nine hundred seven hundred and
then the next day thirty thousand i
don't buy it no no you can't i mean
that's what is that uh well the other
way to check is a 10x increase the other
way to check is to check the create on
date
so go through and look because i've seen
a lot of accounts that are created april
22 now with zero followers i have seen
that okay and some people were tracking
on uh governors actually a mainstream
outlet which one was looking at governor
desantis account and they saw that some
but but it was only like 10 of the
followers were created on in april 22.
so so take a look at this 424 it's 37
425 it's 39. now there's a gain of about
just shy of 200
and 160 that can be explained by
uh
it can be simply explained by monday
more people are at work than they're on
twitter but there's nothing there should
be a larger anomaly because it was 8 a.m
on the 25th when they said elon was in
final talks to buy this
shouldn't there be at least a small
percentage of conservatives being like
i'm gonna follow an astronaut
i i would i would think so so i i think
there's something dirty happening but
back to dave rubin's point
let me let me tell you what's going on
with some of these accounts for one
journalist to buy fake followers i know
all about that and the new york times
likely has
when when you sign up for twitter they
tell you to follow these people it says
follow these accounts and then you'll
just go boo boo boo
new york times is probably one of the
first recommended and it's i get that
constantly if you scroll back on some so
the way to check um people use this for
identification purposes many times
because typically some of the first
accounts you follow will be
geographically um co-located yeah so you
might follow your local newspaper now if
you're in new york that might be new
york maybe you're in minneapolis you
follow the start journal right maybe
you're in nashville maybe wherever you
are right and so some typically if you
scroll back on someone's twitter
followers those are in um sequential
order so you're actually looking at a
timeline of when they followed each
person and in that time so if you go
back to the earliest ones usually the
first two or three are going to be like
new york times cnn or washington post
because that's what's recommended to you
in many cases when you're signing up for
your account they require that you
follow three before you can sign up and
they present those three to you tim how
do you buy followers we just google it i
don't know if you can still do it but it
was it was library used to have it
remember yeah yeah how expensive is it
kind of they're they're more
they're a little bit more a little bit
more professional now everyone used to
be like these macedonian platforms i'll
tell you everybody accuses everybody
else of buying followers and
it you you can't really track this stuff
anymore the the the bot farms have
gotten really good at obfuscating this
um
it what people used to do was track
engagement so they would look at a
certain account
and then run it through some you know
program and it would be like 75 of their
followers don't tweet they're fake
and my response to people was dude if
you go to donald trump
and you run him through this you're
going to see 90 of his followers don't
tweet why they're his fans who signed up
for twitter
they follow him they don't post so you
can't call people fake for that so it's
really difficult to know for sure that
may be true of the new york times the
new york times might not be getting
retweets because
everybody signed up because they had to
they like to well no no no no i don't i
don't i don't comment on the new york
times i follow all these news outlets
i don't engage i see the story and i
click the link i don't there's i'm not
going to argue with a news article i
like jack what you said earlier about it
the real value of these numbers is what
is your follower to interactivity ratio
proven ratio i i in early youtube 2006
seven i started noticing you get a
thousand subscribers and you get eight
thousand subscribers and but i was only
getting like four thousand views i'm
like where's those other 4 000 people i
wish i had a button where i could
un have a bunch of accounts unfollow me
like unfollow me if they're dead
accounts if they haven't logged in in 30
or 60 days because i need to schlep that
that nonsense number i want to accurate
account of who's really there yes yes
yes but ian
uh i'll give some insights to people who
watch this show we produce this live
show we then produce i think between
three and five clips from the show the
next day and then i have three clips on
two different channels
of those videos
the average subscriber watches 10 per
month
so that means if i'm putting up let's
say eight clips per day for 31 days
we've got 248 clips or whatever the
average person only sees 10 of them
so when i'm wondering
the average follower the average
follower right only sees about 10 of the
clips that i put up every every month so
if i you know i have 1.3 million
followers on my main on my personal tim
pool channel
i get 300 or so 1 200 300 000 views i'm
not surprised because of those you know
people you can just basically do the
math some people are diehard fans and
they'll watch every video some people
watch every other video some people
watch a video once a week
yes like accounts that haven't logged in
in 60 days that i'm not interested in
having around anymore but you're never
bloating my numbers but youtube does
delete those
sometimes but i want a button where i
can manually do it i think i'm trying to
tell you to put it on there man let
people see their real numbers
i mean that can be you're the only one
that wants to see your real numbers i'm
joking most people want to see they want
the inflated living on top of the hill
of gold thing it's like you know if
you're going to make that actually like
social currency your follower number
then there needs to be some regulations
about buying fake stuff it's like
counterfeiting money and telling
everyone you're rich
where this comes into an issue is when
when advertisers come up
because if you're using bot traffic and
this was the and i'm going to be careful
about this the previous owners of
newsweek got in trouble for this because
the previous owners before they were
bought out were using bot traffic
to juice their numbers juke the stats
and then present that to advertisers
claiming that they were getting you know
x amount of traffic which was completely
false well so uh back in the day there
was this big scandal around ad rights
distribution or ad rights sales and an
ad right was that
you could have a website that gets a
thousand views per month you sell the
rights to those views to a bigger
network the network aggregates 50
websites that each get you know a
thousand views and now they say we get
50 000 views technically that's true
what was happening was there would be a
company and we'll we'll call it um
we'll call it
golden brand right they're the golden
brand they're the hottest brand they go
to an advertiser look
we get 50 million views per month on
golden brand
now do you want your product associated
with our golden brand yeah then you
gotta pay for 50 million views
and then what would happen is yeah five
million would be on golden brand five
million would be on click farm dot
garbage the others would be on ultimate
american patriot dot info and what these
websites would do is
they advertise
you know top 25 celebrities and then
when you click it
it'll show you a celebrity and in order
to see the next picture you got to click
to a new page
turning one person into 25 views
they can then fluff their numbers up
sell to advertisers it was a huge
scandal everybody was doing it you click
those every time don't you thank god
but now one article or one page becomes
25 pages or 25 but you just answered the
question maybe
i don't understand all this and i get
approached from time to time like
everybody on the web that has a web page
or website whatever
and people call me and say
can i put your website you don't mind if
i put it on my aggregation site right
like this is good for you right i'm like
huh no but you know are they selling to
somebody who's buying ads for them that
what your viewers are yeah if you'll
make a video and this happens all the
time uh the daily wire publishes an
article someone will just quote the
article and then repost them on their
blog called newsjacking right and
they'll do that to try and get clicks
and make money off of it so what they're
doing is they're in some cases they
might be copying your work wholesale and
then wrapping it on their site so that
nobody ever actually clicks through to
charlottesville.com
but you're click you're reading it on
you know whatever what tim is in
clickfarm.garbage
and because they never click through to
your site you don't get any of the ad
traffic
is it too far off the beaten path for me
to mention something about we're talking
about ads
i have a website it's pretty expensive
to maintain in my own it's just a little
thing i do my myself nothing like the
big traffic you guys get i'm sure but it
gets more expensive as more people visit
so i let google adsense put ads on there
you know rotate them through make a
little money to pay my one of my web
guys
i got a notice a week ago that said you
can no longer use adsense and i have
violations for factual articles that
they want me to take down but it's not
over that
you can no longer use adsense unless you
approve our new terms
and then there's no way to approve the
new terms
so i had my web guy look i said am i
crazy there's no way to get in to
approve the terms to continue using
adsense to continue collecting off the
ads
and the web guy goes in and there is no
way to approve the term so i'm in effect
locked out of the
adsense cycle there's no one to contact
there's no way to appeal there's no one
who will answer the question
but i feel like there are these sneaky
ways even if you don't they can't pull
you down
for blatantly violating something they
say you violated they find other ways to
make it pretty impossible to operate
that sounds like an oversight
developmentally
rather than a malicious attack on you i
can't tell but that's what it sounds
like i didn't read anywhere that anybody
else was usually you can google
something like that or search it and
people are saying that happened to me i
have the same problem
and i just don't see other people having
i i definitely saw some a lot of people
talking about google adsense sending out
new terms um i don't i didn't see
anybody mentioning that maybe if that's
a great question if anyone's in the
super chat who's watching or can send
anything in
um but it that does but it reminds me of
you facebook
that recently said i had a violation and
then if you click in there is no
violation and it says if you don't fix
it we're going to take down your page
and you click to appeal and it says
there's too many appeals we can't
consider yours it's a it's to me anyway
it's a trap that i can't get out of so i
just quit using my professional facebook
regarding terms of service this is very
important when a company updates their
terms of service and wants you to click
accept on them what they should have to
do legally is show you the old terms of
service and the new terms of service
side by side highlights of all the
changes so you can click in the areas go
right to the place that's been changed
and see exactly what's been changed
completely unconscionable the way they
do it now let's change it thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there